Hi, welcome to the Ann and Ashley's show.
I'm Ashley and I'm Ann and we are both
started by clinical thermographers here at Conner's Clinic.
Our topic today is going to me on thermography,
but before we get started,
please hit the like and subscribe button
and be sure to hit the little alert notification
if you're watching this on YouTube.
So you don't miss an episode.
What is thermography in?
Yes, so thermography is basically a test that uses
an infrared camera to detect different heat patterns
and blood flow through different body tissues.
So the camera is going to pick up these, take the image
and it's going to pick up these patterns
and it's basically like a topographical heat map
of your body.
And with this information along with kind of an intake form
that the patient would fill out about their health history,
it's sent off to a third party for interpretation.
So medical doctors are interpreting this imaging
and a lot can be determined from these screenings.
There are many advantages to doing it this way
for tracking your health care as far as thermography goes.
What it has to offer is it's no radiation,
it's non-invasive.
It can detect your metabolic function changes
if it's increasing before any other conventional screening
such as mammogram, CT, MRIs.
And then it does go off to those medical doctors
who do interpret the report.
And they are accredited and certified in reading these reports
and putting together something for the patient.
It can also be a great way of measuring your progress
in any treatment you're doing conventional or alternative
and just monitoring your care that way too.
So thermography can be used to track acute conditions,
chronic conditions, and as Ashley talked about
can be used in a preventative method as well.
So if you have chronic pain, if you have fibromyalgia,
if you have dental, periodontal inflammation
that will be picked up, neuropathy can be picked up,
vascular issues, lymphatic congestion,
all of these things can be picked up in a thermography scan.
And while it's great for all of these things,
it's most widely known for breast screening.
So breast tissue is really sensitive to this imaging.
And while it's not a diagnostic tool,
it's not gonna say, hey, this is breast cancer,
it can be a great resource for people who maybe have
a family history, they're trying to just get their mammograms
and they don't wanna be exposed to the radiation
and the physical squishing of tissue.
So we have an image here that gives you an idea
of how in relation to a mammogram,
it takes years before cells have divided
and multiplied enough to become visible on a mammogram
where as thermography can pick up these cellular multiplications,
these abnormal cellular multiplications,
years before it would show up on a mammogram.
So it's really great for breast screening.
So yeah, that image is awesome.
It is, and it's a great, it's really jaw dropping.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, for sure.
So with the month of October as breast cancer awareness month,
we are going to be offering here at our clinic
a special for breast thermographies.
So for a new patient of baseline package would be $300,
normally, it is going to be on sale for $250.
It is also going to have a sale for annual re-scanning.
So instead of $150 for that, it will be on sale for $125.
The reasoning for a baseline package is going to be,
because it includes the initial screening
so your first image, then it's gonna do a three month
all up for the baseline.
So then that gives us two images of who you are,
and that's going to be more of an accurate reading
for the person and the report as well.
So the person who's going to be going over the report
and comparing the two images is going to be more accurate
than just focusing on the one image.
So that is something our clinic will be offering.
We hope you take advantage of this special.
It is really cool to track your progress
and any health concerns you have going on.
You can contact our clinic for scheduling.
Our intake form is on our website.
If you want more information,
we've been more than happy to talk to you more about it.
And then also the prep for the thermography
before you come in for your appointment as well, right?
So that's all we have on thermography.
Again, call the clinic if you have any questions
or want to get that scheduled.
The untolder is obviously great.
Reminder that 10 of year,
I was like, okay, we're gonna get this done.
So this is a great option.
If you would like to talk to us more about anything
that has to do with supplements, nutrition, genetics,
any of your health care concerns,
we do take phone appointments.
So anyone across the nation can call and schedule some time
with us.
The first consultation is always free.
So be sure to take advantage of that.
And always, as always, share this video.
Send it to your sisters and your best friends
to remind them as well to take care of themselves.
Thank you for watching.
Stay tuned for next week's episode.